thanks everyone for coming I'm certainly
excited to have the opportunity to share
with you all some of my my adventures
and unreal fascination and passion for
public data
so yes I'm mark from New York City
originally sometimes I go around the
city with my laptop and a large antenna
and sort of tune into some of the the
fun things that can be overheard on the
the radio spectrum around the city as
mentioned I do a lot of work with kind
of public and government data and the
company enigma that I started we have a
big sort of open source search engine
called enigma public of all of this
stuff that we we aggregated bring
together but I think probably to kick
things off it would be helpful to sort
of get some clarity on on terms and you
know what you know what exactly is
government data and does it really have
a dark web so it's interesting I think
you know one of the easiest ways to
think about like this more expanded idea
of government data is that it's sort of
the thing that's produced every time you
come up against or hit regulation in
some ways you know the we of course we
have these you know sprawling
bureaucracies at you know federal state
and local levels and every time you you
touch them they have a way of kind of
kicking off some data exhaust and from
sort of reconnaissance and open-source
intelligence perspective this can be
really good one of the really kind of
interesting Maps I think at least at the
u.s. federal level to what's going on
from a data collection perspective all
came out of this thing from 1980 called
the paperwork reduction Act and
basically what happened in the 70s is
there was just a massive proliferation
of forms and and sort of you know
government information collection
instruments of all these things and it
rose to the level where the Congress
passed the law and with that law said
was basically every time the federal
government wants to make a new form they
have to themselves fill out a form and
register it with the Office of
Management and Budget which is part of
the executive branch and just
kind of show you here you know this is a
kind of an ordinary tax return 1040 and
it has this OMB Control Number in it and
this is great anytime you have a federal
fat US federal government form it will
definitely have an OMB number on it
somewhere and you know when a government
agency wants to make a new form they've
got to apply to the OMB and one of the
things they have to do is justify why
they need the form and also estimate how
you know what are called sort of the
burden hours of of the forms so right
now there's you know maybe about 10,000
different unique forms that are
registered with the federal government
and what I find extraordinarily
remarkable is that according to the
government's own estimates they require
eleven point three billion hours each
year of people's time to fill out so we
can certainly extrapolate that there's a
lot of information being produced here
just to kind of flag this if there's
something that's kind of interesting to
you guys and you want to explore further
this it's kind of hard to google for but
it's called the current inventory report
I made just a little bit liya that'll
drop you right into the sort of proper
government site and it is kind of fun
because there are there is like an XML
file that has all of this stuff
structured in it and and you can go and
and play with it and so you know just to
kind of flush out like you know what is
this real spectrum of information the
government's producing you know if
anyone's come into the country into the
u.s. from abroad you've probably seen
this form it's one of the most filled
out with over 300 million of them a year
things like w-2 so the sort of you know
tax form for your if you're on payroll
somewhere so the quarter billion of
those produced a year I was sort of
surprised to see that these fiction
Ridge cards or friction Ridge cards
actually they're about 90 million of
them filled out every year and I suppose
it's not all strictly for people being
arrested this one that I just found on
Google Images is for someone applying to
be a pyrotechnic operator so I suppose
these things are produced in lots of
ways and so those are you know some of
the more common forms that are produced
but there also is a really long tail
here so everything from
the 20 or 30 companies that actually
fish off the Alaska coast near Russia
and have a specific form they need to
fill out to the importation of shelled
peas from Kenya and things like the
petroleum supply reporting system which
I'm not sure exactly what it is but does
sound like it could be interesting and
juicy in some ways and so once you start
to know that oh there is a form out
there there of course not all public but
there's a really interesting tranche of
them that are you can start to go out in
and collect information so just as an
example this is you know what a Federal
Election Commission form looks like and
I don't know if you can see it but this
is like a line item by line item sort of
disbursement schedule for all of the
things that the Trump administer
campaign spent money on so we have a
hundred and forty dollar uber credit
there I'll talk a little bit more about
this data set later but the FCC licenses
you know all commercial radios in some
way in the country and you can use that
data set to actually find every
McDonald's drive-thru in the country and
also what frequencies it's linked to the
restaurant with certainly I'm she has
been in elevators you'll see these
little inspection placards
let's run at the state level but that
sort of data that you can get in and
learn all about what's going on inside
of a building you know certainly
aircraft registrations are really
interesting and have tail numbers and
all sorts of interesting joins you can
do with radios this is an example is
just the deed for the hotel that we're
in and when you take it a step further
it's kind of cool because you whenever
their building permit applications filed
for changes use in the space for
renovation there's often sort of
architectural drawings and things like
that so this is also from the hotel the
Department of Labor collects a lot of
information on things like this is I
think for the OSHA so the Occupational
Safety when hazard something a little
bit of a sad case of someone who fell
down an elevator shaft here but there's
a lot of information produced you know
h-1b visas I couldn't really show it
very clearly here but these are the 14
or 15 or whatever it is
h-1b visas that Caesar is applied for
18 and you can see they're mostly tech
you know sort of tech programming
looking people this I just kind of found
and thought was kind of funny it's the
401k plan that DEF CON Communications
has for the four people that are
enrolled in it and this is actually one
of my all-time favorite pieces so this
is a customs declaration from the 1960s
that the Apollo 11 mission had filed
upon coming back with with moon rocks
and so you know it just is kind of a
lovely artifact of bureaucracy I think
and does give us some sort of you know
sense of the kinds of things that do
appear hidden away in the state end you
know I think the takeaway you know that
I want to leave you guys with just from
kind of having blown through all of that
stuff is you know government bureaucracy
can really be your friend I think that
there's you know certainly a key set of
probably sources of government data that
are in our toolkits be they you know
real estate records or corporate
registrations or whatever but this is a
really deep and n stand sort of massive
well of resources and by kind of
thinking about like what are the
processes and how does that potentially
reflect in data you can start to develop
all sorts of new avenues for research
and exploration so you know I have a
personal interest sort of in
software-defined radios and the sort of
AM spectrum and I was really curious to
sort of see how the public data that's
available around usage of the
electromagnetic spectrum could be used
to serve ask different questions over
the world I'm sure this won't be really
a surprise to anybody in this room but
of course you know radio waves are all
around us you know they're sort of in
that really cool sort of spectrum that
takes us from all the visible light that
we see around us to you know the FM
stations in our car and the Wi-Fi and
all of these things are just waves of
different lengths you know of course you
know Marconi is often credited as being
one of the sort of inventors of radio
and it's kind of amazing in its early
days it was you know it's not
surprisingly like a terribly unregulated
and quite
of chaotic technology that was you know
people were just broadcasting and
creating all sorts of interference and
actually a lot of the regulatory regimes
now that we have in the u.s. are said to
sort of come as a result of the sinking
of the Titanic in part because the
Titanic being a new ship you know did
have a radio operator on it and was
sending out SOS messages but the kind of
thought was that there was so much
interference on the sort of land-based
stations that a lot of those messages
weren't received and so that led
eventually in 1912 to the Congress
passing what was called the radio act
which became sort of the precursor to
setting up the sort of FCC regulatory
regime that we have today and so what
you know so we of course now live in a
world where there is a lot more sort of
a tension regulation around the radio
spectrum and that that's actually really
cool and exciting when it comes to
trying to understand you know how this
spectrum is being used so I'm just
curious show of hands has anyone seen
this map before so it looks like about
maybe 20% of people I'll keep coming
back to this sort of throughout the
remainder of the talk because it's I
think a really good sort of touchstone
to understand how you know how a lot of
these things are existing next to each
other so if you see this it's I know a
little difficult to get with much detail
on the screen but it it good is
basically from maybe three kilohertz all
the way at the top to like 300 gigahertz
all the way at the bottom and each one
of those little blocks is a basically
you know a sort of reserved set of uses
that that bit of the spectrum can be
used for so you can see here you know
the FM radio band of course like 88
megahertz to 108 megahertz roughly and
that sort of blocked off there but
what's interesting is you can start to
see that like these things exist you
know next to you and alongside of course
other uses of the spectrum so you know
further down and like the
SiC 150s 160 mega hurt range is where
this thing called a is which is like a
merit like like ship positioning data is
transmitted and then you know further
down in the sort of next block at you
know ten hundred and ninety megahertz or
just about a gig that's where all of the
sort of aircraft are broadcasting their
ship positioning their vessel
positioning data and so I just call that
out to show how these different you know
protocols and uses of the spectrum do
you have a kind of continuity to them
and of course you know there's a ton of
politics and money at stake here and you
know as we know recently you know as
sort of analog television has has all
been shut down that spectrum is getting
sold off and you know just last year you
have twenty billion dollars being spent
you know mostly by the big telco
companies to get access to some of that
stuff that was freed up so you know
needless to say this is like a very kind
of high stake if somewhat obscure and it
invisible is replaced that data is
produced so in the u.s. you know of
course the FCC is the main regulatory
body here and they basically like
collect a ton of different information
and release it in two different ways the
first one which has the most data is
this thing called the universal
licensing system and there's maybe
fifteen or sixteen different kinds of
licenses that we end up giving the
windup get Gowda and each one has a lot
of sort of detailed information
associated with it as part of like an
open data initiative the FCC has done
some work to unify all of that into this
database called the license view
database so I think it's maybe like a
hundred columns that sort of are
harmonized across all of these things
what's nice is it collects in one place
all of these different licenses and it
basically pops out in one CSV file this
is a bitly link to a github repo I made
which basically makes it relatively easy
to if you have a post degree server
running you can basically run the script
and it'll you know download the most
recent version of this database
geocoded geo index it and make it
searchable for you and the cool thing is
once you do that you can actually start
to use this data to ask really targeted
and specific questions about your local
environment in a way so this is I just
did a sort of search of a kilometer
radius around the Caesars hotel here and
said basically like for all the licenses
that have been given out within a
kilometer of here
who kind of has the most of them and
what are the kind of rank ordered counts
of like how the spectrum is being used
so you know probably not super
surprisingly the top three are all like
next house this is your sort of cell
phone stuff but you know then kind of
digging in it was I sort of interesting
for me to start to learn like where
where am I on what's going on around
here
so Perini building company is a
legitimate construction firm that has no
ties with the Mafia but they have done a
lot of the casino construction in Las
Vegas and you know certainly one of the
biggest holders around here and then
sort of drilling down we of course see a
bunch of the casinos themselves are
really big recipients of licenses I was
kind of surprised to see because they'll
come up later in the talk but this firm
Recon robotics which by their own
tagline is the world leader in tactical
micro robot and personal sensor systems
has a good 32 licenses right in this
part of Las Vegas and that in fact puts
them on par with DEFCON who I was very
impressed to see is quite fastidious
about making sure that the official FCC
licenses are all sort of filled out and
one other thing that I sort of call out
here that's I think really important
when to keep in mind when you're working
with these sort of government data sets
is that there can be often a lot of
confusion and difficulty when it comes
to you know doing like entity
recognition and resolution and stuff and
so towards the bottom here we have pH
wlv LLC which I saw is that what is that
and in fact it's the parent company that
it's a Planet Hollywood Holdings that
this casino and many others so then you
know now that you can kind of start to
identify what's going on around around
you geographically how can you start to
use and apply that you know of course
it's been quite amazing to see in the
last several years how cheap
software-defined radios have gotten how
much that's really opened up so for
those of you who don't know you know for
like literally 20 bucks you can get you
know a little USB dongle that will let
you tune into pretty broad spectrum I
think these will go from like maybe 50
or 60 megahertz to just over a gigahertz
um thing like this and they're really
cool and you know very easy to just sort
of get started with this is a program
called GQ rx which is just a really
simple sort of tuner so if you plug in
one of these USB is and you know put in
a frequency you can listen to whatever
might be coming coming across it and so
what's kind of interesting is we can
start to you know not only just look at
like what is the sort of the clustering
of radio licenses around us but actually
dig into them a bit more specifically
and what's really nice about these is
you do get some very high resolution
information about how organizations kind
of operate in function so this one is
for the Caesars hotel it's you know one
of many that they have but it's sort of
interesting is you know the person who
actually filled out this license his
name is Eric Dominguez who is the VP of
sort of facilities and engineering here
and what's also included is his phone
number an email address and it is his
direct line I I called him so I doing it
about to be true and so these things you
know kind of become interesting when
you're trying to think about what are
other ways of you know understanding a
target or a place of interest and
finding things that let you have a lot
of sort of base knowledge about what's
going on if anyone's interested these
are sort of a big tranche of the radio
frequencies that the Caesars Palace
itself has licenses for there are other
ones under other entities that
come up in my sort of first search but
they can be ferreted out and just to
kind of remind us to keep all of this in
context you know we can see sort of
these Caesar Palace radios are in the
the 450 Meg zone but then just a little
bit down the spectrum we've got the
radio frequencies being used for sort of
the control infrastructure around the
the water system in Las Vegas and so
it's a very rich and crowded sort of
space you know but of course this isn't
only limited to these sorts of things so
there's a you know know a 19 is a
weather satellite that's that's flying
around above head it all operates in
sort of the 137 megahertz range and a
friend of mine actually in New York
built an antenna and a G Cal reminder so
that whenever this weather satellite is
actually over the eastern seaboard he
can bring this thing outside and
actually download the images because of
course you know satellites these are
kind of coming down unencrypted and are
there for gathering and that's the URL
for it if anyone's interested but I was
also kind of very curious to see in what
ways different kinds of public data
could start to get joined with what we
know on is available on the radio
spectrum in order to do things like
maybe look inside of a cargo ship so of
course today ships are that you know
really diverse radio stations in and of
themselves you can see here you know you
of course have GPS antennas and maybe
satellite TV you know Pam radio antennas
but importantly up here on the the top
left is an AIS antenna and AIS stands
for automated identification system and
it's basically a radio protocol that is
used for navigation and safety and
whenever a ship is under way it
broadcasts some information included on
this channel and it all basically lives
around
I guess 160 162 megahertz there's two
different channels that it goes on and
what
interesting is if you are you know they
have a line of sight or have a decent
antenna you can actually using one of
these $20 dongles as an example receive
those AIS messages that the ship is
sending off and so here you can kind of
see in this like text box or whatever
those are what sort of the raw
demodulated packet sort of look like and
what you can basically do it's because
there's a you know people there's a
great Python library called Lib AIS and
there's many other ones where we've all
sort of taken the spec and made all the
decoding but basically what data you're
getting when you're listening to these
ships basically breaks down to you know
what you're seeing here and this tells
you things like you know the position
and the heading and rate of turn and
things like that but importantly it also
has this thing called an MMS I and the
MMS I is a sense for mobile maritime
subscriber identifier it's basically
like the cell phone number of the ship
and you can use that to then join with a
second order piece of government data
here I wrote an API that was all linked
in that repo that I showed earlier but
to connect to the International
Telecommunication Union to take that MMS
I identifier of the ship and turn it
basically into the vessel name and some
other information about the ship itself
and once you have this few pieces you
can then get to the place where you can
actually look inside of a ship and the
way that you do that the sort of conceit
here is by taking bills of lading data
that often get filed before ship hits
the port that explained basically for
the purposes of customs taxation
everything that's inside of the ship
that data is kind of made available in a
very crazy way so it's the only way that
anyone can get access to it is by going
to the Customs and Border Protection
office in Washington DC giving them $100
certified check and getting a CD in
return but through a [ __ ] map uh blick
we actually gather all of that
it's free with an API on it and so is
able to sort of stock all of these
things together
I'm just grounding time okay so it's
sort of you know one example another one
I'll just quickly talk about is using a
dsb sort of data which is very similar
to a is but it's for aircraft and
there's a really interesting piece of
work that was done by BuzzFeed
specifically around looking for the
extent to which governments were using
stingray devices which you know often
are put in aircraft and flown in circles
you know when they're going after a
target and stingrays of course are ways
to you know track and intercept Zuma
it's very specific cellphones and so
basically what they did that was really
smart is we're able to take all of the
sort of like flick a DSP flight data and
there's companies like FlightAware and
others that aggregate it for the whole
US and they applied some you know basic
kind of analytics to it to look for all
of the flight patterns over cities where
planes were just kind of flying in
circles a lot and based on that they
were able to identify all of these you
know both airplanes that were like very
clearly registered to Homeland Security
or to a police department but also in
addition all of these new companies that
were shell companies being used by the
government but that they were able to
kind of back into you once they knew
that those companies were potentially of
interest because of these unusual flight
patterns you know there is you know I
think when we think about all of the
different radio devices that surround us
all the time there are a lot of
different opportunities and examples of
taking this sort of contextual public
data and applying them to to those
devices and just kind of enclosing since
we're coming up on time I want to tell
you about sort of another investigation
that I did here around trying to
understand the surveillance
infrastructure along the us-mexico
border so what you're looking at here is
just kind of a slightly interpolated map
of all the radio licenses that are
within 10 kilometers of the us-mexico
border and when I was looking at them
you know did you sort of see these
normal dispersion patterns around cities
of course like the radio towers and uses
are all over the place but what I was
kind of very interested in is sort of
seeing out in some of these more remote
sort of desert frontier places these
very regularly spaced towers that were
being put up along the border and this
one in particular is was put up by a
company called MSR and so I started
looking sort of what is M SAR do well
they make you know the kind of radar
packages that the ground radar packages
that go on predator drones and other
things like that so I thought this could
be interesting to try to dig in and get
a sense of who who and what else is sort
of happening along the border so this is
just kind of like a account of like who
are all of these kind of entities that
are showing up doing experimental work
specifically along the border I just
called out that company Recon robotics
which was the one I had mentioned
earlier is also doing a lot of work
around this hotel but then I sort of one
Piron actually wanted to look at all
these companies and basically you know
found that it's not so surprising but
that in fact the vast majority of them
are defense contractors of different
stripes and so sort of starting to go
through and looking at like you know who
are these companies and what are they
doing sort of you know stumbled upon all
of this really kind of fascinating
technology I suppose anyway so T comm
makes these aerostatic blimps that
introduces surveillance platforms
leonardo DRS is a italian defense
contractor but their purport to have the
most widely used at ground surveillance
radar and you sort of see a lot of these
interesting packages LTA is an israeli
defense company that does a lot of
border security work that's also sort of
working there as is elbit systems and so
you know what's really interesting is
you know you can again pivot from these
very specific licenses or these sort of
aggregates of licenses to then go and
look at like where are the sites and
where are these sorts of things
happening so
you know kind of incredible for me to
just then actually be able to go go over
to Google Maps punch these things up and
start to see all of the sort of sites
where these bits of exploration and and
prototyping this like virtual offense
are starting to happen it just as a like
last piece of context there there was a
bunch of these were part of an older
program that Boeing had was sort of
wound up being a massive disaster they
were supposed to be able to cover the
entire border for 7 billion dollars but
wound up spending a billion dollars to
only do 50 miles and the thing didn't
even work but you know the thing that
I'll sort of leave you with and
hopefully kind of came across in the
talk and sort of through these examples
in context of like what's possible with
data more generally is to really think
about you know not only where these
deeper perhaps unseen bits of data are
but really thinking about how they can
be put together to tell us sort of
brought our stories so anyway thank you
very much
[Applause]